we cannot just eat people
[Music]
you gonna eat anybody else
lady pg-13 what's going on everybody
another new venom TV spot trailer we
probably only have a few more of these
coming out before the movie actually
releases this week I know everybody is
really excited to see it and I'm gonna
go see it as soon as I can this week
reminder about the giveaway all you have
to do to enter is subscribe to my
channel like this video and comment
below with your thoughts and your
favorite superhero for your chance to
win a copy of Avengers infinity war on
blu-ray
some special edition posters and
memorabilia so let's break down this new
venom TV spot trailer so just like with
other TV spot trailers there's a lot of
stuff we've already seen but a few new
scenes to talk about the first one is
very brief in the beginning and as you
can see it looks like venom and Eddie
are bonding again so that means that at
some point in the movie the two of them
are separated from each other now we've
seen many clips including the one that
is at the end of this TV spot trailer
where riot actually rips apart the
symbiote from Eddie judging just from
the trailers it's too hard to say that
this is the reason they get separated
but we do know now for whatever reason
they get separated and it could be
because riot rips them apart the next
scene is really awesome because we
actually see that venom will in fact
bite off people's heads in this movie
some people have been saying that even
though in these trailers venom talks
about biting people's heads off he's
never actually going to do it because
it's a pg-13 movie but as you can see in
this clip somebody shoots him in the
back obviously makes him mad so he walks
right up to him and bites his head off
they obviously don't show the head being
bitten off because it's a trailer on TV
that anybody could see but of course and
the movies it's going to be there this
is actually further reinforced in the
next scene where venom and Eddie are
talking face-to-face Eddie asked venom
are you gonna eat anybody else this does
imply that they have in fact eaten some
people and judging by Eddie's reaction
venom plans to eat some more people then
we have this last new scene where riot
and venom are fighting and riot makes
this giant blade out of his hand up here
and we see him take a swing at venom
and Venom looks just completely shocked
it's been made pretty clear from the few
trailers that we've seen that at least
initially riot will be a lot stronger
than venom riot even has the ability to
create weapons out of the symbiote
something we haven't seen venom do and
we know that there's going to be more
than one fight between riot and venom so
it seems like riot most likely wins the
first fight because again as you can see
here venom is really taken back and
surprised when he's fighting riot here
and it really looks like he loses this
one but I'm sure him and Eddie come back
stronger than ever so that's it for this
new venom TV spot trailer breakdown let
me know what you thought of it and let
me know just how excited you are to see
venom this week don't forget to
subscribe like and comment below with
your thoughts and your favorite
superhero so you can enter the giveaway
and as always thank you so much for
watching Wolf Wolf
[Music]